beautiful that's Britney Spears and her  boyfriend Sam having fun with a filter  but she makes a serious statement to him  at the end of that silly video beautiful  yes and I love you from the pop princess  Spears and Sam who is a personal trainer  in model met on the set of her 2016  music video pure slumber party in early  December he called her his quote one and  only when wishing her a happy birthday  on Instagram  he said Britt shows him the meaning of  being a beautiful woman and a strong  mother so maybe an engagement for these  two this year the singer just ended her  Las Vegas residency  that'll free her up a bit so we can only  hope being said about 2008  you